y las decisiones que tomamos cuando
nadie nos ve define quiénes somos en
realidad
esta es una reflexión de viktor frankl
que fue un psicólogo que por su religión
estuvo cautivo en los campos de
concentración durante la segunda guerra
mundial y entre tantas de sus
reflexiones él nos deja con esta que
cuando estamos en situaciones donde
nadie nos ve las decisiones que tomamos
son las que definen quiénes realmente
somos pensamos en eso segundo qué
decisiones tomamos cuando nadie nos ve
y es que en esta cuarentena muchos nos
enfrentamos a tener que tomar decisiones
sin que nadie nos vea desde si
trabajamos en ropa interior todo el día
o si vemos netflix o si somos
productivos o si buscamos formas de
ayudar
la crisis del coi 19 ha venido a sacudir
el mundo estamos en una situación sin
precedentes que ha sacudido a todas las
generaciones desde los niños hasta los
adultos mayores y nosotros los
millenials no somos la excepción
millenials todos aquellos que nacimos
entre 1981 en 1996 y aunque esta palabra
en realidad era solo para describir una
generación en los últimos años se ha
vuelto casi que el equivalente de un
insulto
de hecho busque millennials on en google
y si bien al final me salieron un montón
de cosas negativas sin embargo dos
milenios somos una generación prestadora
impulsadora de la innovación preocupada
por el medio ambiente preocupada con
nuestros papás y nuestros abuelos y
también por dejarle a las generaciones
que vienen un mundo mejor
de hecho grandes industrias están siendo
transformadas por milenios desde
descubrimiento de drogas hasta
transformando los sistemas de logística
y más aún nuestra capacidad de
adaptación será de las herramientas más
importantes para enfrentar esta crisis
y es que por primera vez le toca a
nuestra generación vivir una crisis de
salud y económica de este calibre siendo
parte del sector productivo y ya no
dependiente si pensamos en las crisis
anteriores por ejemplo el ataque del 11
de septiembre muchos de nosotros éramos
niños
o tal vez adolescentes y veíamos a
nuestros padres como guías de cómo
navegar estos tiempos tan inciertos que
siguieron
ahora somos nosotros los que le rogamos
a nuestros padres que por favor se tomen
la crisis en serio que nos salgan de la
casa si no tienen que salir que
mantengan el distanciamiento social los
roles se han invertido y ahora es
nuestro turno
todos hemos vivido esta crisis de forma
distinta para mí las primeras dos
semanas fueron muy difíciles yo vivo en
california en eeuu y leía en las
historias de italia y españa- el futuro
que nos esperaba
estaba de luto que me di cuenta que el
mundo iba a cambiar y estaba triste por
lo que era
entonces también vino la presión de
tomar decisiones muy rápidos y muy
difíciles y me di cuenta que nunca antes
había tenido una presión así y veían mi
cabeza las imágenes de las películas de
la segunda guerra mundial donde hay
familias que estuvieron separadas o
personas que supieron de sus casas sin
saber si podrían regresar
yo tomé la decisión de regresar a costa
rica esto en el momento donde muchos
países
sembraban las fronteras y cambiaban los
estados migratorios me fui a mi casa en
san francisco california sin saber si
podría regresar
y lo que tal vez para muchos hoy suena
como una decisión obvia para mí una
transformación tomaré la decisión de
estar al lado de mi familia y ponerme al
servicio de mi país
y en esa decisión encontré que si el
mundo va a cambiar pero que en vez de
estar de luto por el mundo que era esta
es una oportunidad de construir uno
mejor
y aunque a veces nos sintamos frustrados
e impotentes en realidad tenemos mucho
poder poder de decisión y en esas
decisiones la oportunidad la
responsabilidad de construir
y nosotros los millennials seremos en
gran parte responsables por asegurarnos
que el nuevo normal que vamos a
construir sea en realidad mejor
muchos nos encontramos con menos dinero
y con más tiempo
y en los últimos años hemos vivido en
día a día con una rutina y una base de
decisiones que tal vez tomamos hace
mucho tiempo casi que en piloto
automático y esta crisis nos ha hecho
pausar es una oportunidad para
reflexionar entendiendo que vivimos esta
crisis de forma muy distinta y que el
poder tomar decisiones es un privilegio
que no todo es tiempo pero que muchos
hemos tomado por sentado
y es que donde nosotros decidimos
invertir o no nuestro tiempo y nuestro
dinero afecta directamente la nueva
normalidad
muchos tendremos que ajustar nuestras
realidades porque la reducción de
jornadas y salarios es una realidad en
todo el país entonces tendremos que
tomar decisiones distintas sobre qué
compramos dónde compramos y cómo
gastamos
pero a la vez nos encontramos con más
tiempo en nuestras manos del que hemos
tenido en años nos hemos pasado los
últimos años en carreras y ahora qué
vamos a hacer con este tiempo porque
nosotros los millennials no tenemos
tiempo que perder entonces finalmente
nos vamos a meter al curso de
programación que llevamos postergando
años o aprender a que el idioma que
siempre soñamos aprender o optar por el
autocuidado y finalmente aprender a
meditar o pasar nuestras tardes llamando
a los hogares de adultos mayores a ver
si nos podemos ayudar
y es que todas las decisiones cuentan
desde las que parecen muy simples hasta
las que son muy complejas yo decidí
regresar decidí dejar de tomar salario
para que mis pares obtuviera más capital
decidí donar mi tiempo a una fundación
que pensé lo necesitaba por ejemplo
volví a dejar la cadena bruja
y nos encontramos frente a estas
decisiones todos los días desde si
pasamos viendo netflix con la compuerta
o si hacemos mil y un malabares para
continuar siendo productivos dentro de
los retos del teletrabajo
donde compramos si vamos al super
alquilamos siempre o ahora que
finalmente tenemos más tiempo vamos a la
feria del agricultor que es más barato
más saludable y apoyamos así los
agricultores costarricenses que tanto lo
necesitan
o si vamos a cenar con la familia y
entonces si pedimos comida de aquel
restaurante que nos encanta y queremos
apoyar o si más bien nos quedamos en
casa y cocinamos ahorramos y es más
barato hasta la decisión que tomamos
sobre la plataforma para pedir comida es
una decisión que impacta
y como quería escuchar un poco de
historia de las decisiones que han
tomado las personas muy milenios de mi
parte decidí preguntar en redes sociales
que me contaran y escuché todo tipo de
historias desde ahora que no puedo
trabajar empecé un emprendimiento o
decidí comprarme una pepita para tener
compañía
y yo tomaré este tiempo para descansar y
empezar a ahorrar
y la última metamos mucho la atención
ser menos consumista y vivir con lo
esencial
y es que como consumidores tenemos el
poder de elegir qué empresas surgirán de
esta crisis y cuáles no
nunca antes la imagen pública de una
empresa había estado tan al descubierto
y había sido tan importante entonces a
quien vamos a decidir apoyar a la
empresa que aprovechó la crisis para
despedir a todos sus empleados cuando
aún tenían fondos vuelves taurán te que
los socios llevan tres meses sin pagar
este salario y le han dado vuelta hasta
la última piedra para poder apoyar a sus
colaboradores
ahora más que nunca lo que decidimos
apoyar es donde ponemos nuestras
apuestas y nuestra esperanza del nuevo
normal que queremos construir
hace años hay un impuesto por un consumo
más ético más amigable con el ambiente
más justo
hoy en día las condiciones están
optimizadas para sentarnos a reflexionar
y alinear nuestras decisiones con
nuestros valores
y yo me pregunto si no es ahora entonces
cuando
y me parece curioso que el mundo en
realidad tenga una crisis económica
porque muchas personas sólo están
comprando lo que necesitan
nos han convencido que los gobiernos y
las grandes empresas son las que definen
el futuro de las industrias del país y
del mundo pero en realidad nosotros como
consumidores tenemos muchísimo poder les
doy un ejemplo concreto la industria de
la leche en eeuu tradicionalmente ha
sido una industria fuerte y robusta en
los últimos años han salido muchas
alternativas hechas a base de plantas y
de nueces muchos consumidores han
decidido comprar estas alternativas
porque son más amigables con el ambiente
y con los animales como resultado la
industria de la leche en eeuu está casi
en la quiebra y esto no fue una decisión
de los gobiernos o de las grandes
empresas fue de personas como ustedes y
como yo que toman una decisión cada vez
que van al súper y lo mismo puede pasar
con usar más energías renovables y usar
paneles solares o cambiarnos a carlos
eléctricos
tenemos en realidad o muchísimo poder de
decisión
ahora está la primera crisis que
enfrenta nuestra generación pero
desafortunadamente no será la última si
estábamos advertidos de una crisis
financiera de hace años sin embargo a
muchos de nosotros esta crisis nos
agarró por sorpresa
entonces qué decisiones vamos a tomar
hoy para asegurarnos que nosotros y
nuestras familias estén preparados para
la siguiente crisis
y es que nuestras decisiones definen
nuestra nueva normalidad y la de todos y
las decisiones que tomamos
individualmente tiene un impacto
gigantesco en la colectividad entonces
qué decisiones vamos a tomar
vamos a seguir apoyando a las familias
más necesitadas comprándole la señora de
la soda qué decisiones vamos a tomar
para prepararnos para lo que viene
entonces yo les pregunto a ustedes
quiénes queremos ser cuando nadie nos ve
muchas gracias
[Música]